-I love seeing you. Oh, my gosh.
It's been three years,
almost to the day.
-Almost to the day.
-Yeah, and a lot of things
have happened.
Congratulations.
-What are you talking about?
-Oh, yeah.
What am I talking about? Yeah.
You have another baby
on the way.
I do. I do.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, baby!
It's the three-year anniversary
coming up, you and Joe Jonas.
-Three year marriage
anniversary.
-Wow.
-I think it's leather.
-Three is leather?
-I think so, yeah.
-Yeah. Interesting.
Do you have any thoughts?
-Not a clue.
-Pair of shoes?
-Yeah, maybe a pair of shoes.
A book.
-A book.
When did you realize, you go,
"Oh, I think I'm going
to marry Joe Jonas"?
-I mean, the first night
I met him, I remember --
like, he left my apartment,
and it may have been
the alcohol,
but, like, he left.
-What was the apartment?
He just came over for a date.
-He didn't come over.
No, I'm not that forward.
We went out and we hung out
at a bar with, like,
all my friends
and all his friends,
and then they all came back
to my apartment
and we had drinks after.
-Yeah.
-And I remember him leaving,
and I just, like, weeped.
I wept to my brother.
I was like, "I love
this man so much!"
[ Laughter ]
And I knew. And that was it.
-So you knew? Yeah.
We know Joe Jonas
as a smooth guy.
You know,
he's got a lot of game.
But then you just told me
something backstage.
You had to call him out on it.
What did he say to you?
-So on this first date,
he was like, you know,
"Do you ever get told --"
He was like,
leading me into this, okay?
He goes like, "Oh, do you ever
get told you look like,
you know, a young celebrity?"
And I was like, "Oh, yeah,
sometimes, but why did you ask?"
And he goes, "Well, I get young
George Clooney all the time."
And I was like, "No, you don't."
-[ Laughing ]
-That's such a funny move.
-No, you don't.
-That's hilarious,
that he would do that.
-I know.
And then I told him,
"Well, I got young Boy George
all the time, so it's like --
the Georges combined."
-Young Boy George Clooney.
Yeah, of course.
-That's our daughter's name,
actually.
-Exactly.
You guys looked great
at the Met Gala the other night.
Of course you did.
Look, this is
a good-looking couple.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Applause ]
Beautiful. Stunning.
You've been to
the Met Gala before.
Do you get starstruck anymore?
Is there any celebrities
you're like, "Ooh, wow"?
-I mean, I'm really bad
around celebrities.
Like, I just can't --
I can't quite fathom
the I'm actually invited
to these things
and I'm not like
a competition winner, you know?
So I mean, every celebrity
I come into contact with,
I act up or
say something stupid.
And recently, it's been if
a celebrity interacts with me,
I immediately just
shut them down and I'm like,
"I don't want anything
to do with you."
And I secretly I'm like,
"Oh, my God."
-"I love you!" "Hey, 'sup."
-I love you so much!
-Yeah, but I've gone too far
the other way before,
so I guess I've --
-What's a recent example?
-So Kendall Jenner was
at the --
Have you ever heard of her?
She's very --
-We've heard of her, yeah.
-She's a niche.
-Yes.
-She was at the Met.
And I love the Kardashians,
but I think she's
so gorgeous in real life.
And I was so, like,
struck by her beauty,
and she, like, invited me to --
they were having,
like, this afterparty,
this low-key afterparty.
And she went, like,
"Do you want to come?"
And I just went, "No."
[ Laughter ]
"No. No, I don't."
And I'm like, why?
Why do I do this to myself?
"I would love to come!"
You're like, "Nah.
No, I'm good. Nah, later."
-And then I just sat in bed
and ate pasta,
and I was like, "Could be
somewhere else right now."
-That sounds pretty good,
by the way,
sitting in bed and eating pasta.
-You know, it wasn't bad.
-Yeah, it wasn't bad. Yeah.
I want to talk about
your new show, "The Staircase."
Congrats on this.
I know the documentary.
I've seen it.
-Yes.
I mean, when did you
get into it?
When did you hear about it?
-I think I got into it
when everyone else kind of did.
I think it was like 2020,
it came out on Netflix
and everyone became, like,
completely obsessed with it.
-It's insane.
And so about six months later,
I found out they were making
an HBO show about it.
And I was like,
I mean, sign me up.
I kind of remember
what happened, but I also don't.
So there's the husband --
-So, yeah.
So this woman,
Kathleen Peterson --
This is a true story.
-Yes.
-She either fell or was pushed
by someone down the stairs.
Unfortunately, she passed away.
And the whole documentary
is following
the trial of her husband,
Michael Peterson,
who they believed
pushed her down the stairs.
-Yeah.
-And so this show is about that.
But it's not another
telling of the same thing.
It actually is about the making
of the documentary
on top of the case
that's going on,
because there's
layers and layers
and layers of corruption.
-Did your opinion change
while you were filming this,
of what happened?
-I'm so done talking
about what happened.
I mean, we were on set
and it was just like --
-I had theories.
My wife had theories.
-Everyone have theories.
And I was theorizing
for so long,
and then by this point,
I'm like, I just --
-Yeah.
-I'm over it.
-Exactly. Yeah.
-It's fascinating.
Fascinating story.
-Fascinating.
-And your great great cast,
Colin Firth,
our buddy Toni Collette.
-Amazing.
-I mean, so many.
Rosemarie DeWitt,
Dane DeHaan, Juliette Binoche.
Michael Stuhlbarg.
I mean, the list goes on.
-I was asking you if, you know,
because it gets intense talking
about this type of stuff.
Do you ever
make it loose on set?
What was the fun things?
And you said
that you created a game.
It's called "Yea or Nay."
-It's called "Yea or Nay."
-That's correct.
It was invented --
Well, I don't know
if it was invented,
but was brought to me
by Odessa Young,
who plays my sister
on the show.
-Wait, someone actually --
I thought
you invented this game.
-I didn't invent this game.
-This is a real game.
-I can't take credit for this.
This is real game.
-Can you explain to everyone
what this game is?
-It's very basic, but basically,
it's a great time waster.
So one person is the subject and
everyone else secretly decides,
"This is the end position that
we want this person
to end up in."
Okay, so you choose
a physical position for them.
It could be like this.
It could be like,
climbing on the wall.
It could be anything.
-You all decide that
that's the position.
-And you all decide.
And then you just kind of
let the subject go
and move around the space,
move their body.
And you say, yea
if they're getting warmer
to the pose,
or nay if they're not.
And I think we should play it.
-We should play this?
-I think we should play it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love this.
I love any game.
I love anyone bringing a game.
-Are you down?
-I'm down. How do we do it?
-Get yourself up.
-Okay.
-I will...
You know, conveniently,
there's a whiteboard here.
I don't know how that got there.
I will write down the position
that I want you to end up in.
-Okay. I'm not looking.
-I'll show you guys,
the audience.
-So the audience is in
on the position?
-Yes.
-This is "Yea or Nay."
-And then we will
say yea or nay,
depending on if
you're getting closer or not.
-Okay, "Yea or Nay."
And this is a real game
that someone made up.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, can we see?
-You're showing?
I'm not looking.
-Yeah?
[ Applause ]
-Our audience likes it.
Alright. Is it away, Sophie?
-It's away.
-It is away.
It's gone.
-Okay. Alright.
So now are we currently
playing "Yea or Nay"?
-We're currently playing.
-[ Laughing ]
-Move about the space.
I'm moving about the space.
Okay.
-All: Nay.
Nay.
Yea.
[ Laughing ]
Nay.
Yea!
Yea! Yea.
Yea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You did it!
[ Bell dings ]
-Wow, I'm an expert!
At "Yea or Nay," I'm an expert!
-I can't believe you got it!
-Is that what it was?
-Yes, that was it!
All fours on desk.
-Oh, my gosh.
-There it is.
-All fours on desk.
That's what I'm talking about!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Yea or Nay."
You are the most fun.
I want to show everyone
a clip.
Here's Sophie Turner
in "The Staircase."
Take a look at this.
-Hey, Dad.
-You guys unwrap presents yet?
-No, not yet.
-They're not going
to do it themselves.
-I know. It's just --
It's not the same without you.
-Honey, nothing
feels right about this.
-The D.A. keeps calling.
-Well, you just
keep ignoring them.
So, have you spoken
to Candace Zamperini?
I haven't gotten through.
-Uh, no.
What, really? Nothing?
-No.
-Look, just make sure
everyone sticks together.
I miss you.
-I miss you, too. We all do.
-I'll see you soon, alright?
-Okay.
-I love you.
-Sophie Turner, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The first three episodes
of "The Staircase"
are streaming now
on HBO Max.